has played the role of acting being at
times as h NS a-- energy SI so once when
i teach him about being the acting st
english i know he said it's probably
because everybody knows that he doesn't
really seem to give me out joel is a
pioneer of urban environment of history
in the winner of the 2008 in order da
Vinci medal awarded by the Society for
the extreme technology for contributions
to the field of history of Technology he
was also one of the earliest winners of
the robber Geordi price of Carnegie
Mellon substantial and sustained
contributions to excellence in education
very widely published with three
prize-winning books such as technology
and the rise of the network city in
Europe and America the search for the
ultimate sink and devastation and
renewal and environmental history of
Pittsburgh and his regions and numerous
numerous papers Joel came to Carnegie
Mellon 1967 after receiving his master's
in his bachelor's from Rutgers and
appeared in American history from
Northwestern in Pittsburgh upon the
confluence
that have been certain for the study
since industry technology and the urban
environment and their mutual
interactions at CMU to he found his
colleague engineers who studied urban
technological systems the Society of
history of Technology Award citation
some sub Joel's work best in his new
news release of the da Vinci award
headlines envirotech me your car is the
da Vinci metal degrees since the 1990s
one of the most exciting developments in
historical study that's been the
convergence environment to a
technological history Joel our third
tower began to explore this time with
convergence a generation earlier his
scholarship both painstaking in
pioneering has pointed the way for many
scholars now working at the intersection
of technological and environmental
history from the late 1960s to this day
as a scholar educator and citizen he has
generated net human billing systems and
values with the natural environment
beginning his career at the nevada story
he asked new questions he found new
sources and synthesize a new range of
interdisciplinary approaches at once and
in mind
urgent and technological historian
George are demonstrating possibility and
irrelevance of labeling subfields when
the unifying and ultimate topic is the
story of humanity's interactions with
the nonhuman world we welcome Thank You
Indira I really thought I was wonderful
i really appreciate it i've done india
for many many years she's been an
immensely valuable friend over these
years and he's made huge contributions
to the University the class that
occupied this room before I came in was
a class looked at them controlling
dynamic systems and as I thought about
them my life I realized it was really
dynamic systems out of control you see
it's really quite a challenge to them to
deliver a lecture like this or to think
about it because you try to puzzle out a
balance between personal on the one hand
and professional on the other hand and
you also have to think very carefully
about how many secrets you want to
reveal because I have been in
administrative post several times of
course and i do have a chest of papers
and digital recordings and things like
that hidden away somewhere the only
problem is I forget where I put them so
that he may never be revealed at anyway
when one thinks about one's life course
he can become very philosophical and you
begin to think about issues like well
maybe it's all an accident you know Oh
an accident who are you think about the
fact that without that opportunity you
know things would not have happened or
you think about the fact that without
that particular mentor who helped you at
a key turning point things wouldn't have
happened in the way they did so it's
really trying to trying to understand
how you got to where you are what key
turning points they were and what key
events they were now
when I receive this metal lead out onto
vincy metal I was really astonished to
receive it I'm first of all because they
don't think of myself as a historian of
technology and that's why the title of
this talk is why technology is really
this is originally composed to try to at
the time was being given that award I
said one knee you know why technology
i'm not a history of technology of an
urbanist i can confess to that i'm also
interested in urban environmental
studies very deeply i can confess to
that and also the role of technology but
still i am not a historic technology and
I think my engineering friends will be
astounded at the extent to which I think
of technology as a black box that is not
necessarily understanding how it really
all works and I'm Phil my wife of be
glad to tell you how what huge
difficulties i have and operating the
VCR and things like that without
instruction book the bulletins and so on
so what i'm going to do today is try to
trace some of the events key events in
my life both personal and professional
i'm going to try to do it using some
slides some images are like to do that
and I've really found by the way that
since they're coming a PowerPoint and
all the images available to use a
lectures my research career has been
destroyed because I spent so much time
looking for images to use and putting
them together in power points but some
of them had some of the things on that
have come up of course have been
particularly interesting no I when I
received the award and had to start
thinking about talking about my career
in some way I had already begun
exploring this somewhat because I have
been asked last spring winter to write
an afterword for a book in honor of a
very bright young environmental
historian in withheld Rothman who died
of Lou Gehrig's disease at the age of 49
and the title of the book was nature in
western cities and I said to the editor
will I don't write about western cities
I'm interested in primarily in eastern
cities Midwestern cities
he said it doesn't matter just write
something so I've then I realized so
that well I was not writing or
researching the western cities I really
had tried twice in my life very
significantly to move into the west and
to become a westerner that is I made a
trip to Arizona for a year in 1952-53 so
something about that in a second and
then I went back in the 60s and actually
taught in California for six years
before coming to Pittsburgh so the title
of the essay that does the essay that's
the afterward of this book is escape to
the west return to the east the lure of
the city familia and basically but what
were at what i do there is try to say
well what is the magnetic force that
pulls me out of the glories of Southern
California sunshine and ocean and all
those things too dirty smoky industrial
Pittsburgh so that's a profound kind of
question at least it was to me well I
grew up in Jersey City and I don't know
if any of you know Kevin Lynch's
writings about um urban planning and so
on but he has a wonderful phrase on in a
book on urban imagery about people go
through jersey city you will know who
know who live in jersey city well you
ask them the question have you been
there and they say yes I've been through
it I've been through it because you have
to go through jersey city to get the
heart to the Holland Tunnel you have to
do get to get to Manhattan in different
ways so you go through jersey city so
it's a place where people actually go
through an awful lot but people do live
there also and it was it's basically an
old industrial city across the Hudson
Bay I'm from Manhattan and as I first
thought about the talk this talk that I
was going to be giving for the metal
first ago on now again here I realized
what a large imprint jersey city had
made upon my consciousness upon my head
it's stamped there as a matter of fact
as I will explain a little bit perhaps
even more drastically everything you
might imagine well security city young
as he said an industrial city
and disappointed this here and I want to
start off with this image here because
this image includes a picture of my
father this is my follower right there
he's working at that time in the federal
ship rods and in Corning New Jersey he
was working at night in the federal
shipyards and he's working days in a
supply house plumbing supply house he's
they were wounded his sleep not very
often but obviously there was a lot of
things technological artifacts in my
life technical technological images and
that picture which was on the front page
of a young company magazine mele the
Navy was in charge at that time in 1943
have been saved by my mother and I'm
immensely glad I was able to reclaim it
and I've used it I have it all over the
place my house and and so on in my son's
house my daughter's houses because it's
such a meaningful kind of village you
know in terms of saying where do you
come from what does that mean and this
is a picture of the shipyards that my
father worked in they were launching
destroyers and other kinds of boats
during the Second World War this is the
little hardware store that I opened in
1944 and that store existed from the
1944 to the late 60s and at that time it
went bankrupt because of competition
from highway stores and I worked in that
store from the age probably of about 12
until I went off to college and against
a well more experience with tools and
machines and nails and screws and all
those wonderful things that relate to
technology yeah but i just sold them I
didn't necessarily explain how to use
them so thumb but it was a very
important experience obviously in many
ways i funded one place where I lived
and during the war itself I could
actually see the Statue of Liberty and
then we moved in 1944 to another place a
possibly high place from which I could
look over the city the downtown of the
city and she's a Pulaski sky
way which is right over here and the
jersey city is surrounded by an immense
amount of industrial technology bridges
movable bridges of all kinds all the new
technology mostly old I think probably
and it's impossible to get away from the
fact that this is the center of some
important stage in the industrial
revolution now living in jersey city
could be quite an adventure in terms of
again technological systems and networks
this is a picture of a elevated street
car that I used to take all the time and
I didn't really think about it I guess I
got a little concerned about on the
fragility of the structure itself but on
the other hand only it was quite an
adventure and this was the this is a
picture of the Hudson and Manhattan
tubes and the tracks there by which you
were journey to Manhattan which he did
an awful lot actually beginning when I
was about 12 or 13 years old I took the
tools as they were called to Manhattan
never thinking at that time of course at
at one point in my life I begin thinking
about Subway's tubes bridges and things
like that in a more systematic kind of
way now I used to ride this trolley car
all the time the street cart and it is
um it was amazing i was able to find a
picture of it actually but there are
street cars like that all over jersey
city just as like there had been in
pittsburgh by the way in 1960 by the
time like even 67 many that were gone
but you know that I'm and about 90
before the First World War actually
before nineteen forty Pittsburgh had
over 400 miles of streetcar track in the
region a lot of people road cars like
that they recall light rail cars now of
course now this is a very famous bus as
far as I go again I was amazed to find a
picture of it the closest of this is the
bus it changed my life now maybe you
think a trolley car change your life you
know what is that how does that song go
clang clang clang in the bells of the
trolley car and so on well this is a bus
that changed my life well how did it
change my life it changed my life
because when I was 14 years old with a
very gray cloudy January morning I ran
into the side of one of these buses the
head down bounced off the side of the
bus hit my head on the concrete sidewalk
on the curb and didn't wake up for 12
and a half days and I suffered a brain
concussion obviously I lost my memory I
lost my ability to walk I was but they
couldn't operate because they didn't
know where the pressure was in the brain
I remember waking them way of waking up
in the hospital and saying I got to get
out of here and say well maybe I'm here
for a reason maybe I shouldn't that's
probably a story that somebody told me
but it sounds good at any rate so this
is an immensely important event in my
life that bus is a very important bus on
and on because it changed my life that
because I became a rabbit hunter as this
picture might suggest but because after
I had that accident I had to really let
me learn many many things I essentially
took a very different direction in my
life of the direction I are taken before
then i had read always been a voracious
reader of books but I basically was not
doing well in school at all my back Mike
I was told the times my parents thought
I might have been retarded and it was
very very didn't Darrell math in do well
in English didn't do well all those
things they're pretty well in geography
and history but basically aside from
that and not very well I didn't
necessarily focus after the accident and
after my recovery a bit to focus in a
way I hadn't before but did that mean I
suddenly decided was going to become an
academic you know we're going to move on
and take that path at journey well not
at all as a matter of fact but a lot of
different things began to happen
and that were going to influence the
track that I was going to take in life
one of the things i wanted to do very
much was escape from jersey city
something about a book as a book
actually by the title escaping jersey
city i wanted to escape in jersey city
and so I with my freshman year in
college to the University of Arizona in
Tucson I went out there and I've never
really been out of Jersey City before
that I could have gone to the moon going
from jersey city in the New York
metropolitan area to Tucson Arizona
which had 90,000 people in it in 1950
it's really a jury to the moon for me
and I had decided by Thanksgiving that I
couldn't possibly survive out there I
tried I bought a gun as you see here we
go hunting with my Arizona friends and
colleagues are by the way I only had um
my friends were all on the two sets of
people of this University once said with
playboys Danny I knew my girls who came
to have a good time and the others were
native Arizona people who had no money
to have a good time but they like to
hunt and sports and I tended to hang
around with the latter so I bought that
gun and the only significant thing I
ever did was it worth it was almost
shoot my roommate but I did solve it
before before I left I left it now so
this is scape from the place where you
grow up whether you really have deep
roots is very very significant and let
me tell you a little story that's out of
chronology on this and that is at in
1961 when I went on the job market for
the first time one night I received a
phone call from a man who identified
himself as Monsignor O'Grady the Dean of
the College of Saint Peter's College in
jersey city and he called me up and he
said done we spoke to me said listen
we've heard you're a very good teacher
from your mentors at Northwestern where
I was during my graduate work then he
liked off your a job right now over the
phone that was back in the days when
there were a lot of jobs obviously right
now over the phone and I said to a very
stunned and I said stop for a second
on seeing you I don't where did you say
you were from Jersey City he said yes
that's NFL for another minute and I
sediment seeing it I don't mean to be
presumptuous and I'm very appreciative
the author of the author but I must tell
you that i have spent most of my adult
life trying to escape in jersey city and
that's the true story as a matter of
fact so i ended up going to California
as a matter of fact which they were
later line to escape them to so anyway I
loved Arizona and I went to Rutgers
University and when I got to Rutgers
University in New Brunswick New Jersey I
looked around and said how could have
possibly gone to the crass undeveloped
uneducated uncultured West when this
kind of wonderful colonial college was
within very close range of them of my
home 18 miles where I live I actually
lived on campus but he used to come home
every weekend and work at my father's
hardware store very significant is it
significant not only because there's a
place it wise that its meaning you
significant because of the mentors that
I was able to acquire there in
historians primarily you love somebody a
fellow in English too it was a small
school there was only forty four hundred
men on that campus when I went there in
1953 and there about eleven hundred
women on the douglass campus on the
other side of the town was not
integrated males and females yet so and
and one day I was taking a history
course in European history and the
professor said to me whose name was
Henry Winkler not the Henry Winkler
he said what are you gonna do with your
life and I said I'm going to become a
high school history teacher and he said
no you're not he said you got to go to
graduate school and until you know when
somebody says something like that to you
showing some kind of believe in your you
know they certainly see something there
it is domestic meaningful and I stayed
friendly and close to Henry ever since
then he himself became president of the
University of Cincinnati executive
director of the American Stroke
Association and so on but he um a very
important person not the only important
person there because of the professor's
I had that were wonderful mentors very
well-known historians well in this 1956
in September 56 actually before the
summer of 56 I got a job at the edison
laboratory national monument in West
Orange New Jersey has arranged a
historian well what do they do at the
lattice and laboratory National Monument
they made technology they made
photographs they did chemical
experiments they did things with light
bulbs and they made movies I used to
show movies in the first movie theater
not theaters actually was a studio AB
that existed the black Mariah as it's
called and the machine shop at Rutgers
was something i was quite familiar where
they used to show people around it if
you think see the kind of threads that
have to do with some kind of technology
i know it's all technology has nothing
to do with them the wonderful
technologies that I struggle with every
day here but there were technology
surrounding me okay so I did that and
then I left Rutgers with the Masters it
went to Northwestern University and I
studied in northwestern and I had some
very fun teachers but there are two
events that stand out in my mind there
in terms of how i trace my journey and
that is two things that happen there
were primary
really accidents had made it possible
for me to survive because I think
without them we would not have survived
the first thing had to do with the
language requirements with the ph.d
program most history programs in the
United States at that time required two
languages usually French and German well
I struggled through my friend barely how
is it going to deal with the German in
the Lear before I came up for my
examinations they changed the
requirement for people in American
history from two languages to one
language okay no undue influence
exercised is a stroke of maybe
somebody's watching over me the second
important thing that happened there that
was really profound in terms of making
really my survival involve my my assume
dissertation director very well-known
historian as they was to offer length
the biographer of woodrow wilson and i
took i take my courses and I was taking
my prelims and authors there and I'm
sure he had funk the prelims there were
four people on the exam two of whom I
had never met one of whom was my worst
enemy in the department and then author
so I was I had about two hours of
drilling and no sure I flunked and
author said okay go outside the way to
the steps will come and get you ready
when Alan sat on the steps assuming I'd
be there for at least an hour and
suddenly author comes running out and
says to be 12 really in one sense he
says you passed congratulations do you
have a car well how do you put it he
said I forgot that today was my son's
birthday and I had promised to take him
and his friends to the movies and the
movies is going to the movie is going to
start in about 20 minutes and I have to
get home I'm still convinced it was out
that or a fairly flunked bike railings
I had to take them again yeah in May I'm
sorry get you yes I did have a car to
drive it to msi it really is really
really ironic I'm that it happened their
way and author was a well-known person
who forget we got a lot of things and
under reminded often than my wife that
I'm always forgetting things to you know
so I guess it's the role of wives to
tell you that you forget most of the
time all the time okay so anyway I went
to Northwestern I lived in Chicago for
four years and I began to feel about
Chicago the way I felt about jersey city
no longer was an escape in Chicago a lot
of a jersey city alone is no escape from
Chicago when I was there Chicago was
corrupt very corrupt more than even now
it was filthy they never cleaned the
streets they never took the ice and snow
off the streets it was a very difficult
time and there was a great deal of
social turmoil I live for most of the
time and she lived in Chicago on the
south side which is the one of the areas
where there was an awful lot of clashing
between whites and african-americans
over housing questions so I decided I
had to get out of color of Chicago and
that I was going to go and was going to
accept the job that has offered in
California and California was the Golden
West it was had to be quite different
than arizona had been arizona's very dry
and at cactus olap all over the place
california was the golden worse to have
the ocean and so on so i would go to the
golden west and try my life there my
experience there when i went to what was
then called Long Beach State College in
long beach california very unique kind
of place long beach california fairly
sizable city south of Los Angeles on
every year they but I said they used to
have a huge Iowa picnic and they would
have a hundred to 150,000 Iowans were
living who are living in Long Beach come
to this picnic so it was you know for an
Eastern kid tell me from a basically
racially
the kind of mingled city of mingle where
people mingle is really astonishing to
be in that kind of environment and I was
basically uncomfortable living in
Southern California even though again I
had some wonderful colleagues while I
was there we just go on with this this
is you know this is pretty hard to take
you got to realize but this happens to
be the University of California at Santa
Barbara where I taught from nineteen
sixty five to nineteen sixty six or 66
267 I'm sorry is a visiting professor
but living in Southern California in the
60s was difficult first of all you had
was the 1960s and I guess I don't have
to tell you much more than that but I
was convinced that if I stayed there
with all that Sun and all that ocean and
all those young beautiful women in
bikinis around my research career was
over my my life as an academic was
probably finished it was very very hard
to focus and I therefore began to look
around to move and I did finally move in
1967 from Santa Barbara where I rather
than go back to Long Beach and I moved
to a place than when I apply to her
known as carnegie institute of
technology carnegie institute of
technology which is which is located i
heard in the industrial city of
pittsburgh but i had actually visited
once when I had a cousin of mine get
married here who married a young woman
from Lebanon now divorced by the way but
they're not particularly significant so
the I came to Pittsburgh at that time
and there are still people who wonder
how I traded that for that I mean what
was going on what kind of good sense do
you have and don't you really appreciate
the good things in life well the stuff I
really appreciated was being obviously
it seemed to me the kind of place the
kind of place that I felt comfortable
with and that was the kind of place
they've grown up with a have a link
again has a wonderful book called what
time is this place I could never tell
what time the place was in Southern
California
but a Pittsburgh you always can tell
what time is this place I could always
do that in jersey city also now I want
to make a point about Pittsburgh and the
University when I came here the point is
that they were both undergoing huge
transformations they're both being
transformed California was growing very
fast but I never had the Philly who's
being transformed in any way except to
extend the freeways and the tract
housing but how do you melon first of
all Pittsburgh first of all and sorry
was experiencing really at the tail end
of it was called the Pittsburgh
Renaissance he came to really redevelop
an old industrial city the first major
attempt to do this of any industrial
city in the world and it had made a
number of strides forward particularly
in environmental ways but it was still
unfinished this is you can see the two
bridges of the point still there you can
see Point Park has not developed yet and
so on along the line this is a picture
of the people who are running the show
in Pittsburgh at that time the Allegheny
conference and Community Development
which is headed by the way for 12 years
by Rick Stafford who is in my first
class that I taught at the school
government and public affairs in 1968
and 69 what did Richard stop had become
a member of the elite he certainly did
he's a power broker he's also a
wonderful guy so these were people that
were really hired in a way a sense of
them they need to improve their
environment in a way that a lot of other
elites in other cities didn't have
because of this just moved away to a
different location you have to realize
that Richard King melon could have lived
anywhere in the world he wanted to live
and people like that and but they stayed
they stayed and they tried to improve
the city that they lived in so again
well the city was many ways dirty smoky
still a lot of industry who was trying
to improve he got a sense of the fact
that there was a momentum underway okay
the bottom of the university though
until nineteen sixty seven Carnegie had
been carnegie institute of technology
it was no longer Carnegie trade schools
as it had been and certainly under
Robert Dority particularly the president
from the late 30s into the 40s and it
made blood strides and dirty himself was
quite involved with the Allegheny
conference and improving the city
improving the city of Pittsburgh so in
many ways in 67 when I came was a very
exciting time because at that moment
just about that time carnegie institute
of technology it combined with the melon
institute and the melon family had given
them 12 million dollars to help create a
new college the college of humanities
and social science we better already
receive money to start GSA a few years
before that by the way I was never Dean
of GSA I would never have accepted that
place being Dean there I'm sorry no I
was then that GSA no no no and I don't
even find out scientific enacting doing
there either although we're going to be
here to do that all right so at any rate
on it was a very exciting to come to
this place at that time because it was
undergoing vast range and and the to
depart places I was associated with that
came to the joint appointment between
the Department of History and the school
of urban a public affairs now called the
hind school thought super as was called
that a soup obviously but it was on a
professional school and was a new
college created an H and SS of course in
many ways was enlarged from what it had
been and you had new things going on in
history for instance you had had the
creation of a doctor of Arts degree and
the doctor of Arts degree he was really
I put forward by under the direction of
Ted Fenton who was around here very
significant person in the history of the
University and who ran the dr. BOTS
program and recruited people to that for
some years and I was the person teaching
the required research seminar in the
doctor of Arts program the people he
recruited at the beginning were
outstanding people there were people
that have been out Tiki in many cases
open you know I played will
rolls in the outside world they were you
know what behind the years students and
out some of them from the four students
that I came to direct to gain that DA's
there dr. Watts degrees all did
significant things one was Mike Weber
who became tenured faculty member here
in history and later on became the vice
president Provost at Duquesne University
another one was Theriot see who was now
the CEO of them the world Environmental
Council and Tony Penna of course who
became drew Dean here and later became a
provost at Northeastern University and
tomato who became head of a software
engineering program here in the masters
of software engineering you say wait a
second where did that all come from you
know of the history degrees they were
Jim did his dissertation by the way on
softball an irrigation system central
pivot irrigation systems in Kansas
there's my suggestion and that just just
amazing wrong from the part of these
people so they're really a great great
group so you have super going on we're
bill Cooper images this is just
Pittsburgh stuff all your Carnegie it
didn't look quite like this when I came
this is little earlier but it did look
very different from this and you might
say even today it doesn't but that that
wouldn't be entirely true notice the
similarity between that machine carpet
carnegie institute of technology the one
in Edison's meet place that i show do
another thing about this is of course
right close to the time i came you
notice there that it's not pointing but
you can see the streetcar they're
running up forbes avenue in find of them
in fact in front of right up by warner
hall but I came from my interviews I
remember sitting them in it was in the
summer like getting somewhere in the
fall and seeing streetcars on Forbes
Avenue when I came back that summer to
take the job they were all gone and to
our great sorrow I guess in many ways
but um basically the decade that decade
in the following decade were very major
earning points in my life and let me
just shifted the personal for a second
which I've talked about a little bit and
here again an immensely catastrophic and
important event in my life of a very
different kind and that is in 1969 my
first wife who are married 1956 died
suddenly and I had a five-year-old down
boy and a year and have old daughter and
I did where I was untenured also at that
time and I I was immensely fortunate at
that time in spite of a huge loss to had
through the help of friends and help of
a retired social worker who became a
really a wonderful baby nurse a
substitute mother for me to help me four
years to really pull myself out of that
period of anxiety and depression and to
try to move on with my life and get on
with my professional life and basically
to get my children also those two older
ones plus it to more I had later on
which I'll talk about in a second
getting getting them moved on a path in
their life my daughter my oldest
daughter who has two degrees from
Carnegie Mellon University now as a
social worker in Seattle and my son
Michael is the thoughts professor of
Ophthalmology whatever that is in visual
sciences in the Department of cognitive
and linguistic Sciences at Brown
University so I'd say that them they did
a right and I take of course great pride
and how well they have done and it's
just talked about Michael for a second
the college professor I don't know why
he moved in the direction of cognitive
science after all his father was a
historian even though he hung out hung
around engineers it may have been
because three houses down the block from
our house rice Ready lived on the corner
Raj moved in there and just slept too
long after we move there in fact on the
other Cohen Alan Perlis who is the first
head of the computer first the head of
the computer science department in this
university also lived when I first went
there so we're sort of surrounded by
cognitive scientist
sinoway and Michael was obviously
influenced and influenced by being close
to the University it's on we have an
interesting story in the family the
story is that when he was growing up I
used to whisper in his ear no English no
history no philosophy math computer
science well when he won a few years ago
in the APA awarded him a young scholars
or young the early career contribution
to psychology and he told that story in
the biographical profile that he wrote
on in the journal one of my very good
talented graduate students had a wife in
psychology and she ratted and saw it and
she showed it to him and he came running
into my offices but what is that kind of
stuff talking to your son about history
in that kind of way so I said well he
had good mathematical ability and we
didn't want to lose it but any rate I
guess he did forgive me all right now on
my life change very dramatically also
again in 1876 when I met my present wife
tova who's sitting right here and I
can't point out I was a laser pointer
because it's not a good thing to do and
told her I told him as I'm i met her
either through design on the part of
friends of ours for friends or on a by
accident so i'm not sure how to answer
that particular kind of thing both right
at that time she was a graduate student
she's an israeli she'd come to this
country 1971 to study always intending
to go back to her homeland she was
studying for a PhD in education of
psychology at the University of
Pittsburgh we met and two years later I
was able to persuade her to stay in this
country to to marry me and and help me
create a family and we had two more
children we have two girls we're poor
children l and one of them one of them
is in law school and the youngest one is
who spent last year in Ghana is
unemployed in Washington DC so if any of
you have good contacts and
so at any rate I was immensely lucky
because of the personal things that
happen to be the disasters in the one
hand but also my good fortune and being
able to survive them okay now let me go
back to my professional life a little
bit I don't want to your time I don't
know what your time is like you do you
want to oh yeah that's fine I mean he's
25 30 years are easy to cover in that
space of time right okay now where we
turn now back from the personal to the
professional and in many ways what
happens in the 70s and the 80s is that I
begin to hang out with different kinds
of people and when I came to Carnegie I
was just finishing a study of urban
politics in Chicago but it began working
on a question involving transportation
technology and its impact upon the city
and at that time we had a Institute here
called the Transportation Research
Institute whose located where range of
Morgan's domain is right now engineering
public policy and it was run by a just
most elegant man Jim amaldi who Makka
pakka thiis dress only stressed exactly
correctly and he was quite scandalized
when new faculty came into the College
of civil engineering like Chris
Hendrickson and never wore a tie and
never wore a jacket he didn't know what
had happened to the world you see at
that time but exam was a wonderful man
and he actually sorry you said hey
historian could be put two in the
Transportation Research Institute and
they began funding my research that
began participating with them at that
time also though and probably through
from the people in TR I I encountered
another group of engineers under the
direction of another incredible person
Bob Dunlap and this is a group of
engineers I'm not entirely but largely
engineers
different engineering disciplines who
bought into a vision that Bob had about
the kind of role that engineering should
play in society not only a technical
role button' role it also involves
taking on public policy problems i'm
trying to deal with them and doing
things that are relatively broad
interdisciplinary kind of way and I've
actually have a number so this is bill
Cooper by the way who's the first Dean
of a supe he's a former boxer by the way
and no one tried to avoid it getting too
many arguments with him but there's the
other thing I remember about super and I
don't want to tell too many tales out of
them you know what it's a church out of
school right but I remember very well
did super used to always have a
associate dean or came out of CIT well
super used to hold its promotional
meetings there's 10 de meetings at night
at a dinner at a dinner was great dinner
steak dinner whatever sometimes but they
used to serve hard liquor the day oh
look if they actually scotch and and and
bourbon were on the table and so on and
I'm very well coming out after one of
those dinners and bill gowan so at that
time was associate dean between the two
schools and say I said to me tell me it
didn't happen I can't believe it
happened you know it really was
incredible kind of situation there well
anyway a bill for whatever reason was
just to step down by dicks I it than the
president and his place was taken by
Toby Davis an economist who have been
very very critical in the founding of
supe and who told me that so many years
later that he had really been the one
who pushed for a historian know he's a
micro economist but he obviously had
some kind of feeling that history could
be useful in a certain way this is the
picture by the way of Ted Fenton who I
mentioned before was so important i'm
sorry it's jay bad picture I just
couldn't find a better picture of whom
and this is raj ready young I'm sorry
that's right ready who um who of course
became the first Dean of the School of
Computer Science here very famous on
computer scientists and my neighbor
familiar
and Bob Dunlap Bob Dunlap who left the
university and became self a firm called
Rita is very very important for him in
the environmental area very successful
from came back to serve as a university
trustee year played a vital role here
and then passed away suddenly just
several weeks ago a great really a great
tragedy he's just a most amazing human
being and again one of those people that
you meet you know you know it's going to
be a long time before you ever meet
anybody else like that anybody he met
and touched of course was immensely and
this is young important but demand
that's the affected now so I'm just see
I had another couple pictures okay
there's a few other folks that de bruin
that early crew this is the silly crew
of people who get involved with
engineering and public affairs as was
called then later EPP Francis McMichael
who is a sanitary engineer at that time
but lady became an environmental
engineer was the end of the melon
Institute and he was recruited by Bob to
come over into that particular group and
in addition Henry paella and
metallurgist who's still around even
though he says he's retired Brooks
harder than he had before Eddie Ruben
who's still around here of course and
still active a TPP and Peter starlings
anybody said he's a historian what is he
doing with this bunch well Peter was a
person that I recruited actually in 1975
I was chair of a committee to come and
fill a chair that history had again lot
fortuitous peter is a very famous
historian we didn't at that time history
was trying to move ahead but you know
still was not a distinguished department
why did Peter come here because it has
to be a divorce and he had to get out of
where he was he comes somewhere else and
we often miss charity came so you know
got a school I don't think that's out of
school just shows you how human and how
these things often affect them the
direction that
erection of events Pat Grayson who
became the Dean of HSS in 1975 a herb
Simon student GSA and later on became
the vice president of this university
who also passed away I last year but a
very significant figure very tough guy
became president of Georgia Tech after
he left here he was not successful down
there and I remember him saying to me
who could understand those southerners
you know just completely different
mentality so at any rate there's a lot
going on i guess that's really what i
want to give your affiliate effect was a
lot of change in the air there were new
programs going on we had a feeling that
carnegie mellon was really gone to move
ahead that we were on the makers
university and we dick side does the
president it really gave you that kind
of feeling of energy and going somewhere
we were relatively small still then
everybody worked very hard and
supposedly side went around and checked
offices on Saturday mornings to make
sure faculty in GSA at least we're in
their offices this is before you had
home pcs you see and and everybody that
the slogan of Andrew Carnegie was my
heart is in the work right so this is
going to be the slogan of this
university so it was a could be a very
rough ride you know here it could be
tough a lot of people fell by the
wayside but if you worked hard you know
where there is possible to be a survivor
and I think more than that it was
possible to be a survivor by involving
yourself in the university is a totality
does where is going rather than some
special little kind of isolated niche
which might have been true for
successful professional careers in other
places but was not so true here okay so
um in the 70s from Bob Dunlap who was
wonderful entrepreneur put Frances
McMichael and I together and persuaded
us to write up to submit a proposal for
a grant
in the area of retrospective Technology
Assessment strange kind of term isn't it
and there are 85 proposals submitted for
that granted to our astonishment we
wanted with one of the four that got
that grant and that really began my
career in the sewers that sounds like
really going down into the waste water
but it really was immensely important
also i had already begun doing some work
on issues of them problems of
environmental problems and sewer
problems but this is a major grant
supplied money for graduate students and
research and also the opportunity to
work with people like Fran and there's
also a third person on the ground to
those along with us his name's David
wujek what was Roger he was a
philosopher of technology this
philosopher technologies become a fairly
well-known opponent of global climate
change as well as quite surprised to see
that range of an eye let's jump is
biography again but at any rate um we
put this team together and we began to
produce a series of papers and reports
about the development of wastewater
systems in American cities over time
what the key turning points were but the
key individuals were and so on along the
line and it was a very really I think a
very significant kind of project very
much out of the usual academic mode of a
history book so much so that we couldn't
get it published but um at least his
articles is ever going to get the whole
thing probably many articles that came
out of it but nobody is willing to take
it on as a book but anyway again by
being put together with people like Fran
with whom I formed a lifelong bond was
just a really familiar wonderful
experience in a growth experience
because they learned so much about
things I knew so little about again the
Stephanie's work significant too because
Bob and I also put together a proposal
to the Andrew W mellon Foundation in the
era of technology and society that was
also funded and we got three hundred
thousand dollars of five years at a time
when $300,000 was real money
and then we got a successor grant for
another five years so through that money
we were able to set up a series of
programs providing for the hiring of a
historian of technology providing for
interdisciplinary courses being told
jointly in some cases by historians and
engineers by social scientists and
engineers and so on research and
development courses and things like that
get money to provide for a speaker
series and technology and so and along
the line it's really a the first major
interdisciplinary kind of activity of
that sort on the campus and finally one
last thing that happened that was
innovative during that period of time
well as it'll be had become quite clear
to Peter stones in myself that the
doctor of arts program we've really had
to go it had to go not because it had a
great success but it had to go because
no longer were they recruiting the
exceptional kinds of people they have
recruited in the beginning and also Ted
Fenton to a certain extent I think had
become tired of it had lost some of its
vitality and we realized that the
Department of History to do well in
Carnegie Mellon University it had to
become a research-oriented department it
didn't become a research-oriented
department if it's state oriented
towards curriculum design and things
like that it would never get the respect
even though that was meritorious worth
respect we felt was important on the
university so that history would no
longer be seen as a service department
but we'd really be seen as a place of
real research took place and we were
able to get that degree approved in 1980
and to set up a ph.d program that became
a PhD program at that time between
history and social sciences is called
applied history and social sciences in
the history department itself dan
Resnick who's here is going to be
speaking I know I'm in a few weeks
played a key role in starting an
undergraduate program oriented towards
what we call applied histories and it's
now called history and policy so that
history and policy is a focus of the
department of history became something
very important on the undergraduate
level and
the gradual level now moving in this
direction and having all this money to
throw around and I did have a lot at
that time unlike today's when I guess I
don't have too much in the pocket meant
that done I sometimes got into trouble
particularly the department heads that
did not like the fact that I was pretty
independent and finally I got into a
bang down knockdown fight with the head
of the history department at that time
whose name shall not be mentioned and I
decided enough and pray son recruited me
to go down to social sciences where they
don't see any people down there's a new
department and I went down there for
nine years and so I moved from history
to social sciences I kept the connection
in super at that time and on the 80s for
me as a decade were decades we're a
period when I began to encounter
administration or why people would make
what to make me an administrator no I
understanding at all particularly
because my had this fight with this
particular department head but in
nineteen eighty six hours recruited to
become the acting dean of super Bryan
berry famous geographer and a horrible
Dean Bryan berry had resigned in
mid-year the set during the Second
Bunnies be evaluated the second time we
was up and so I remember very well on
how Jordan the Provost at that time
coming to my house fourth child was
about a year old a year and half all
then and became he came to my house to
ask me what I do this take on this task
and I remember my wife saying to him but
what's going to happen to my baby it has
to be well at any rate at any rate at
that time I took all in that task I went
back to history after I came back from
super though but if Peter had asked me
to rejoin the department of the
department is really moving ahead and
then Steve Feinberg another very
significant person in my life we could
it be to serve as this associate dean
for a year well you know how long those
things can extend to and I ended up
spending three years as associate dean
for Steve Feinberg if this
H&S s and then would it steved him he
left he would often york university to
become a vice president and i ended up
being acting being of a gnss so i did
that for a year but you clearly did not
want to take on a task of being full of
Dean all the time and by the way it's I
think you have a very strong position if
you're an acting person you don't care
what happens you can do things you
wouldn't do you know if you really cared
about making enemies by taking some very
important strong steps John never lied i
know John never let that stand in his
way I always moves ahead and he can but
don't ask you the Dean right now but at
any rate um and then I you know I had
this kind of acting career not only did
I serve as Acting d intervention SS and
I came back was acting handed the
history department for a year so i
really forget thinking seriously of
applying to the College of Fine Arts and
what happened was that actually in the
1980s and 90s have began to associate
with people in fine arts David Lewis
who's an incredible urban designer
biographer painter sculptor bon vivant
somewhere around here was his there is
right there and when I began to
associate in the urban lab and in the
wind and in the various urban programs
with droid programs we've joined
students and it was going to be
immensely rewarding then again another
link with the College of Fine Arts came
in the middle 90s when a very
strong-willed man very strong opinions a
person who loved to fight an Irishman
building of Tim Collins came to campus
and Tim Collins came here is a visiting
environmental artist with his wife reiko
Goethe and one date in college was
looking at a story in the newspaper
about the plans for always
was today is somerset and for the valley
in frick park where there's a huge slag
heap and he noticed in the plans that
they had proposed to culvert the stream
there take nine mile run and put it in a
pipe coveted they said that shouldn't be
urban streams are a wonderful resource
so what Tim began to do is put together
a team of people including Bob the young
who's here although you may have been
one of the initiators and called me up
an interview and enlisted me and again
in the middle 90s at a time when I
should have probably been thinking of
retirement I got recruited to serve as
part of it into disciplinary team
working on this kind of environmental
project and it is a really significant
project as career accomplishes great
things that Steve Feinberg if you don't
know this is the way the valley look
this is a team from nine mile run
walking through the valley in 1996 this
is their trailer that they had down
there to begin to develop the valley in
a groove is a green cara de and to
uncover the stream and to work with the
corps of engineers to uncover the stream
and this is where it looks today is
obviously an amazingly important
contribution none of the city in the
region of the United States it is the
largest example of urban stream renewal
in the United States and for me again
chance to associate with people like
Collins and godo and Bob Engel and so on
who come from a very different set of
disciplines than I do think differently
than I do and was immensely rewarding
and growth really groove Ben diamond
really meant growth so my journey you
see my journey there was changing
directions at various times not always
because of anything I did but because by
good fortune and people like Tim Collins
are coming to the University and so on
the last point oh yes there's one more
team that I did become very involved
with two in 1999 which is more or move
back towards engineering but still
environmental I'm in 1999 I wrote a
proposal
um sue McNeil a wonderful civil engineer
who we'd love to get back here and Paul
Fischbach was sitting in the back to do
brown field studies in the region and
again that was funded and we began
projects in terms of brownfields
studying brownfield renewals old
industrial areas renewal here that was
quite successful in many ways and
resulted in the creation of the
brownfield Center and dev was sitting
here a moment ago they she is and that
was part of that team and she's now
directed the brownfield center and also
of the Steinbrenner Institute so you
seen the way the way in which people
coming from different directions often
coalesced here alright the last point I
want to make my sleep every motor home
well I'll talk about that in a second
the last point I want to make is about
my Pittsburgh involvement if you
remember I came here escaping from
Southern California and I was not
disappointed in what I found and we
might have been by roots in jersey city
you see but I was also able to get
involved in projects such as done mile
run such as the environment the work i
did hear such as the brownfields that
related to the improvement of the city
and the region and in one thing about
pittsburgh is that it is a place where
you can get involved doesn't matter who
you are it's possible to entry into
serve many circles it's quite easy
people are quite glad to accept your
resources and your energy if you're
willing to devote it and I became a very
very devoted to the to the city as a
whole and some of you may have noticed
that I have a care that dumb I got 1991
was called an alumni chair but then see
Feinberg said to me you know you can put
anybody's name on that that you want so
I asked my i said to my son but what
should i do and he said um well you're
you're very involved in the city
pittsburgh wanting to put the name but a
bit of a berto Clemente's name on the
chair and i said well you know I wasn't
so sure about the Roberto Clemente chair
but then I had an idea that dick alaguri
who have been the mayor
city for 10 years were a new pipe well
who had died just a couple years before
that in office wonderful wonderful man
that I could use his name and I was able
to get approval from his wit out to do
it and so I became a kallah jury chair
and I really linked in with the city in
many many ways many many activities I
feel that I belong here I wouldn't even
go back to jersey city now and I you
know I think that my experience here fun
from the city the region but also from
the university has been so dynamic and
important in terms of the journey that
I've talked and I can't imagine having
gone anywhere else where I would have
been able to go and do the things that
I've done I moving the directions to
penetrate disciplinary boundaries you
know and to work with people from other
disciplines as far as wonderful
historians also some of whom I was able
to recruit like David Helen show right
here very noted historian of technology
but this kind of this kind of
involvement beyond a limited domain I
think it's very very important all right
whenever I talk to graduate students or
I talk to new faculty I try to talk to
them about that reach out you know meet
people of the disciplines try to get
involved with them and other kinds of
projects don't stay necessarily what can
be called the history world now that the
history world is an important it is but
it is not the only world okay let me
stop there thank you for your attention
thank you very much hey everything
questions will be glad to try to oh the
horse Louis in 1971 but I was working on
transportation project I kept the money
to materials that talked about the
problems at horses postman cities horse
manure dead horses and so on so a wrote
a little article there was an American
heritage and it was only accepted there
after a fight in the editorial board
because some people thought I was
apologizing for the automobile and it
was published and then I moved away from
the horse away from the hospital and
into sewage this is step forward and
then in the late 90s I realized for
people that people are still regarding
the workhorse in a way they shouldn't of
that is it was not only a polluter it
were made it possible for the city to
operate so I got together with a
girlfriend of mine who had been calling
him on here for a year climate change
and we wrote a book called the horse in
the city living machines in the 19th
century because the horse was a machine
was more important than the steam engine
too much of the 19th century cities
would not have operated without horses
playing all kinds of roles well last
year the American Museum of Natural
History in New York City and exhibit on
the horse that was co-created by Sandy
Ulsan who's a curator of anthropology of
the museum here and they had these
horses the horses the machine in front
of the museum and so now that exhibit is
opening in the Carnegie it's going to be
at the clinic Efus for five months as a
matter of fact I urge you to go see it
because it really brings out the many
many manifests roles that the horses
played over time okay